you don't have to be plus size to experience fatphobia
and I think that that concept is one of the reasons why people
gravitate towards the term
mid size so often
even if they're not actually mid size
I just made a video like
going into detail about the term mid size
but basically
the only people that actually should be calling themselves mid size (if they want)
are people in that
like in between between straight sizes and plus sizes
I’ll come online and I'll see someone who's like
literally a size medium call themselves mid size
that's not what that word means
you could still be curvy and straight size
I'm gonna use my girl Nicola as an example
first of all I love this woman so much
I do not play about her
and I think she's a perfect example of it
because she often gets called plus size because she is curvy
and specifically has had a rounder face
but she's like a very small human being
she's very petite
so despite her being curvy
I don't think that she would actually fall into
the category of plus size clothing
again someone can correct me if I'm wrong
but I'm like pretty sure I'm not
and so I think people that have this experience where they are not
like Societal's idea of what like
being skinny and thin is
but they are not like fat like me fat
like plus size fat
so they gravitate towards this term mid size
and I understand again why people use it
and because she exists in a curvy body
she does experience fatphobia
but she's still straight sized
does that make sense
to clarify just because she's not technically plus size
doesn't mean you can't see her as representation
because like despite us being very vastly different sizes
I still do really love her and appreciate seeing her on my screen
and feel represented by her
because like film and TV is so specific about the bodies that they do show us
and uplift on screen
that anybody outside of that norm is beautiful representation
in my opinion anyways
again I'm using her as an example
this is not like an invitation to like
say anything negative about her or her body
I love that woman with my whole heart
yeah I just wanna show you as an example that like
you don't have to be plus size
or even mid size
to experience fatphobia and be impacted by fatphobic beauty standards
like you could still be straight size and experience all of that